PROFESSOR: Welcome to this
session on separable equations.
So in this problem, you're
asked in the first question
to solve the initial
value problem
dy/dx equals y square with the
initial condition y of zero
equals 1.
In the second part
of the problem,
you're asked to find
the general solution
where no initial
condition is imposed.
So here you need to remember
your method of separation
of variables to tackle
the first question.
And then in the second
part of the problem,
remember all the types of
solutions and conditions
that you applied the first part
to recover the lost solutions.
So why don't you take a
minute, pause the video,
work through questions a and b.
And then we'll continue
together when I come back.
Welcome back.
So in the first
part of the problem,
we'll be solving the equation
dy/dx equals y squared.
So here the method of
separation of variables
tells us that we should regroup
the variables of the same kind,
so all the y variables on
one side and dx variable
on the other side
of the equation
and then integrate
from this point.
So here for this step,
notice that I divided by y
squared, which
means that we need
to impose the condition y not
equal to zero from now on.
So from this step, we just
use indefinite integrals
to integrate both
sides of the equation.
So the left-hand side is the
integral dy over y squared.
So integral of this
gives us minus 1 over y.
And the right-hand side,
integral dx, is just x.
Both sides would give us
constant of integrations,
but we only need
one because this
is a first-order
differential equation.
And so we group them together
on the right-hand side
with constant c.
So from this point, given that
we're interested in variable y,
we need just to
invert the expression.
And that gives us
partial answer,
which is y of x equals
minus 1 over x plus c.
So now we need to use our
initial condition, y of zero
equals to 1, to
determine the value
of c for this particular
initial value problem.
So our initial condition
was y of zero equals 1.
So if we substitute
this in the expression
that we just
obtained, we just have
zero plus c, which then
only gives us c equal to 1.
So we end up with the value for
our constant of integration,
c equals minus 1.
And so the solution
to this problem is
y of x equals 1 over 1 minus x.
So if you examine
this expression,
you see right away that
we have a problem for x
equals to 1 because
at x equals to 1,
we have 1 over 0 which means
that, then, the solution blows
up and we have a
vertical asymptote.
So let me draw this here.
So we're going to have
an asymptote at x equals
1 and a solution that passes
through our initial condition,
y equals 1, going to infinity
when approaching x equals 1.
But then on the right side
of the value x equals 1,
we have another part of
the solution that goes
to zero as x goes to infinity.
And that diverges to minus
infinity when x approaches 1.
So by convention, the solutions
of differential equations
are defined on one
single interval.
So we need here to realize
that the solution we had
is basically two
parts, the parts
on the left of the
asymptote and the part
on the right of the asymptote.
So the solution to
our initial value
problems needs to
be the solution that
passes through the imposed
initial condition, which
was y of zero equals to 1.
So it needs to be this solution.
So now, if we move on to the
solution of the second part
of the problem, b, we were asked
to find the general solution
of the problem, which means
that we need to account now
for all the
solutions, regardless
of their initial condition.
So we already answered
this partially
during the solution
of part a where
we solved using
indefinite integrals
and arrived to the
solution minus 1
over x plus c,
where here we had,
basically, an undetermined
constant of integration.
So this is one general solution.
But remember that
we need to give all
the solutions of the problem.
So when we arrived
at the solution,
we excluded the
solution y equals
zero, which was basically
a lost solution because we
had to impose the condition
y not equal to zero.
So we need, when we give
the general solution
to this differential equation,
to recover the lost solution.
And then we basically have
one kind of solution, minus 1
over x plus c, that
excludes y equals to zero
and another kind
of solution that
is simply the zero solution.
So to summarize,
the important points
of this problem is to remember
the separation of variables
and how to use it and
the fact that using it
imposes conditions that require
us to recover lost solutions
at the end of the
problem if we're
asked to give general solution.
Another point to remember
is that even a simple ODE
can lead to relatively
complex behavior which
drives the presence of
this vertical asymptote
that you need to then know
how to deal with and determine
which part of the solutions
that you've obtained
is the real solution to
the initial value problem
that you're given.
So I hope that you are
OK with this problem
and you will use these
approaches many times
for the rest of the course.